(upbeat music)
- It's punching.
It's kicking.
Armored combat is sort of
like, uh, MMA, but with weapons.
To me, this is the ultimate combat sport.
My name is Andre Sinou,
I'm the co-founder of
the Armored Combat League.
I'm the captain of the
national sword fighting team,
the USA Knights.
Our form of armored combat started
a little over four years ago.
It came to our ears that
there were some people
over in Europe that were doing this
and we had to build a United States team
and try to be competitive with the world.
Most of the arms and armor that we use
comes from the late 14th
and early 15th century,
Western Europe.
Now there's some other armors
but the best bang for the buck
is usually late 14th century,
early 15th century armor.
It's kinda counterintuitive,
but if you're wearing
decent armor and you get hit with a sword,
half the time you don't
even know you've been hit.
(clanking)
If you played football,
you've done a rougher thing.
It's a brawl, I mean
there's no doubt about it,
you're going out there
and you're brawling.
Just like in rugby or football,
you've got to have a plan
when you go out there.
The flankers end up with
three people on them
and you end up with two.
Now melees are a lot more intense.
Those rules are, you
fight until submission,
or until you put somebody
down to the ground.
(banging)
There's no typical person
for armored combat.
You've got people from all walks of life,
whether it's some sort of martial arts
or football or rugby, there's
some history buffs too.
And they'll fight and fight and fight,
and they'll give everything,
to the point of exhaustion.
That's what makes a winner.
It's all here.
These guys will go hard at each other.
They're gonna be swinging
as hard as they can.
They're trying to knock you down,
they're trying to get you to submit,
and then they're gonna help you up,
they're gonna pat you on the back,
and they're gonna go have a
steak and a beer with you.